[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
to the show man it's the playoffs
finals is almost here Ryan we're not
counting out your Celtics yet even
though everybody in the world is
Ryan don't think his team is done but
Ryan everybody in the world thinks you
guys are done let's give you the floor
Ryan do you think the Celtics is done do
you think no dude by the way I would
like to say man you jump in these
meetings and and you know you start
talking to your friends and everything
and you realize how many basketball
sharks there are in the world because
it's 3-0 and they're telling me it's
over I'm like oh my god dude who would
have thought no dude no we got a game to
play tonight and let me tell you this if
the Celtics win a basketball game
tonight which I think that they will
they gotta go home and then protect home
court and then if they win that game all
of a sudden all the pressure goes on the
Miami Heat back at home in game six
that's all I'm gonna say that's all I'm
gonna say turn the table win one tonight
I like it I like it I had that same
faith when the Warriors was uh you know
we were down and you know I thought the
ties were going to turn so I I applaud
you in having that faith in your team MB
talk to us main first basket killer my
man's been killing it with those first
baskets how we feeling on this fine
Tuesday afternoon
we're good baby I'm actually just on the
other side
um I don't know if this series is gonna
be a long one but I do think the Celtics
will have some success I'll I'll get
into that a little later but since you
mentioned first basket
I'm going Marcus Smart tonight going
with Gabe Vincent and I'll tell
everybody why a little later
there it is there it is
his first basket takes and he's gonna
drop it again at the end of the show so
don't go nowhere but while I'm here let
me welcome everybody to the show my name
is Greg Ivory too you guys left is the
man we like to call producer Ryan our
Celtics fanatic here today and uh to you
guys right is the man we like to call
Envy he is the man of the F and he is
also the first basket killer and B I
think that that's your new nickname for
me first basketball every time I see you
old Tick Tock every time I see you on
Instagram you are cashing another first
basket but guys
we have yet to cash
one of these parlay bets in a while so
we want to switch it up we gotta go to
the bullpit we got to go to I say
I say bro let's just make this parlay
even money like let's just try to get it
even close to even money let's see one
go through the hole and uh go through
the hoop and let's just you know
let's ride off into the sunset what are
you guys thinking
I mean I'm not gonna argue with you
because it's been like what 84 years
since we hit one of these so yeah
hopefully us hopefully us putting in a
bunch of minus 5 000 legs will amount to
something tonight I mean damn I gotta
win something
though
the question of the day is do we have
Ryan's buy-in because we all know we on
this show my man Ryan loves the plus
money right do we have the buy-in today
you got to buy it from me my head is so
in on the Celtics winning a basketball
game tonight that well I'm just here for
Vibes let's just let's just do it
right do it this is the least resistance
we're ever gonna get from
Ryan's about this season
we're going to take advantage that all
right we're gonna hit this probably I'm
sending off Good Vibes into the
atmosphere uh we're talking heat Celtics
you guys know the deal Ryan
people was talking about in that chat uh
well my guy KJ Mullins jumped in here
and said man my guy listen the Celtics
are freaking done they ain't winning at
Miami only reason they win is because
Scott Foster is head ref tonight and I
wore this shirt
if you guys can see what it says here
just for my my Miami fans because I knew
they were gonna pre-cry uh before
tonight so I just wanted to get ahead of
that but uh he also dropped Kayla Martin
two plus threes I don't know if that I
don't know if that is the place we want
to start uh considering that uh we want
something a little bit more safe but we
can check it out
he well he's hit two threes in a lot of
games in a row so maybe we make it just
one three
yeah he's definitely gonna hit one right
and we're gonna try and get to eat we
need to like we need like the for sure
guarantee here we know he's gonna make
one and what are those odds at oh minus
a thousand love it that's my type of
play right there
go ahead go ahead Greg what'd you have
no no no I was just going to re reassure
that that's my type of play I was just
gonna say I told you guys about Caleb
Martin like a couple parlays ago you did
yeah he's been doing his dougie dougie
you did you did you did that's that's
actually I was gonna say man I'm you had
the drop on Caleb Martin that one day
and he had like 10 points in the first
half but I see BK in the comments bk37
saying Max struce over eight and a half
points I don't know what his number is
at but let's check it out his number's
at 11 and a half so if we go eight and a
half it's minus 330.
okay I don't know minus 209 that puts us
in a good spot that does that's only
three baskets for him too yeah yeah yeah
the way he shoots it do do we think do
all right so here's my question for you
I mean in all honesty in all honesty the
minus 500 is calling my name it's I
don't
let's see
let's see what we let's see what else we
can find we see B Thompson in the chat
saying Jimmy plus five assists
God damn it no no why this is not a
Miami Heat parlay like the Celtics I get
it bro like I really do I understand why
you would bet this way if you've watched
the first three games but like we're
going for minus 500. how is Jason Tatum
20 plus points not even being considered
here wait hasn't even been said
well I was that was gonna be my next
point because I really wanted you to
sweat about the fact that we were on all
all Heat plays but it's pissing me off
let's take
I like when you get mad that's like my
favorite thing
thanks Jason Tatum
24.3 minus three thousand
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa fellas fellas I know I don't mean I
don't mean to rain on the parade here
because you know I'm all about these
these minus 2 000 plays you know what
I'm saying as long as they add up to
make sense you know what I'm saying but
at the same time
I mean JT scored 14 points last game
Ryan yeah I know that I know that
he averages 27 in elimination games Greg
27. okay
27. I mean you you winning me over I
just I just had to hear from your mouth
you know what I'm saying so I don't know
bring this up next week
also also also I'm gonna I'm gonna make
sure I make my comment here I do not
want Jalen Brown anything anywhere near
this parlay nowhere that man been
smoking parlays for the entire
postseason I just can't see it
yeah uh also BK said Jason Tatum fourth
quarter points under one and a half
[Laughter]
guys this many points in the fourth
quarter of the Easter Conference Finals
that's unbelievable oh my God wait what
about uh are we locked
okay my bad go ahead yes sir B Thompson
sang Brogden two threes two threes might
be too many but that's definitely gonna
make one yeah yeah we'd be lucky if he
hit one okay
wait wait wait
that just might be too many
yeah
think about think about how funny it is
the difference between this parlay and
last week last week we were all over the
map but now we're like well he'll make
one I'm sure hopefully I am legit I'm
Legit crying laughing bro
s go to Brogden one plus three and let's
lock this far land I don't bro I don't
know if he's gonna make one have you he
had like three air balls last game oh my
God man oh no new game new game new game
uh right yeah what's up backs are
against backs are against the wall he's
gotta make a shot
yeah he's got a big boy
I kind of like Al Horford better than uh
better than Brogden to be honest and he
definitely shot better last last week or
last game he definitely shot better last
game Al Horford so the volume's gonna be
there
Al Horford
wait to make one
KJ Mullins says Grant Williams over 0.5
poking the bitter
Grant Williams has scored 20 points
under take the under that's like a
Hammer Hammer lot of the century I don't
think we could be betting on Grant
Williams
no no it's not there it's not available
Derek white or Al Horford to make a
three because KJ Mullen sang Derek white
two threes
um
what's I mean I got to see the number I
mean obviously I feel better about Derek
white hitting the three but that's minus
1500. so I mean that's what Big Al
right we gotta add it in and it'll be
plus but
oh
I mean it is only one basket
that's one three I love this far late so
much
legendary let's let's see uh bagel and
lock saying brogdon's averaging 5.1
threes attempted this postseason I know
no trust me I was on bronze at four plus
three's last game
no
wait wait because I can't do it
we're on him four plus threes last game
but you don't think he's gonna come out
and make one today well because I used
my eyes last game did you see he shot
like seven of them three of them missed
the rim completely new game bro it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter his ass
is gonna be on the bench
okay okay can I ask you this question go
ahead I can't guarantee I won't be angry
though go ahead
do you think the Celtics win tonight
yeah
okay if you think they win the night do
you think Malcolm Brogden will be a
piece
of the person
right he's gonna make one
I
I think he will thank you Ryan you are
in hell right now dude don't even act
like you're not you are in hell right
now he'll be a piece of the puzzle but
he'll be like that quarter piece you
know what I mean you don't like you you
needed to get started but you don't need
it to finish the puzzle
I understand what I'm saying so you feel
more so you're more confident in Derek
white than than uh than Brogden yeah you
see a Derek white shoot Derek White's
been smacking him I love Derek well
we're at plus 100 boys I feel like we
shouldn't we shouldn't Tinker too much
this isn't a bad look right here how
many legs do we have we got five five if
we wanted to if we wanted to do four we
could take out one of the Celtics one
plus made threes and bump up Jason Tatum
to like altered it 22 and a half scored
[Music]
it is a new game
[Laughter]
the only reason why I like the 20 points
is because we could see something like
we saw at LeBron last night where he
gets 20 in the first half like we want
to cash this by halftime honestly that's
the that's the hope and the prayer so I
say we let it ride man it's right at
even money
he B Thompson saying that he's putting
his name and his reputation on the line
of Brogden two plus threes
we're not doing two
no we're not doing two no we're
definitely not do it too
I don't know the funniest thing I think
that's the funniest thing of 2023. it's
like Andrew Andrew Bostwick Andrew
Bostwick said this parlay is poop emojis
and you're right but if you're first
coming to this show we haven't hit
anything in so long we're trying to see
one go through the hoop brother sorry
that's actually a compliment that he
said that it is
and that makes me feel good inside that
he said that the parlay is like I
I'm confused about that like that's me
walking dead baby
I will say this I like this take from
miguelito Smart two plus threes he looks
so locked in today I why do we not talk
about Marcus Smart at all not two plus
threes we could just do one because
we're trying again trying to get this to
look good like
I I would I actually feel very confident
and more confident in this
White
yeah now we're gonna give ourselves
another
another five bucks maybe yeah it's plus
110. so if we did this hey
I like it Kayla Martin strews over eight
and a half Tatum 20 plus Horford one
plus Smart One Plus
all right I like it big I like it I like
it I like it
even though I think Malcolm Brockman
makes one um but yeah I like it Greg
Let's uh let's side bet Malcolm Brogdon
to make one for like one plus 15 bucks
or something
oh I know he's making one
if we put 15 on it at minus 1500 what do
we win a dollar
a couple cents
all right I like it let's let's roll
hey hey yeah plus 110 Ryan are we
locking it in yeah I'm down I'm in I I
like this
that's how we feel it Ryan likes it I
like it and be like it Ryan
um he review it one more time for the
people or do you want you want me to do
it this time since you you think I give
you crap while it's on like that would
be that would be awesome that would be
great if you could do that
Caleb Martin one plus made threes Max
streams over eight and a half alternate
points Jason Tatum two score 20 plus
points out Orford
one made three and Marcus Smart
one made three not two not two
but one made three at a pretty pretty
price of plus
110. this is this is so me this is right
up my alley
right here you're a natural dude that
was beautiful right here that was
beautiful
I say next season this is your this
should be your this should be your job
next season
we got hey we got a lot of episodes left
yeah we might have parlay
go ahead I was gonna say we might we we
might have uh we might be talking about
a new series next week so this job may
not last that long what do we do
hey uh if you want to tell our parlay
make sure you guys head on over to
FanDuel but Ryan in the meantime between
time can you please tell the people
what's up yeah if you're new to FanDuel
uh you want to tell us you want to fade
us you want to bet something completely
different you know go for it do whatever
you want to do but uh bet five dollars
and get
150 in bonus bets guaranteed over at
FanDuel uh 150 is a lot of money and
bonus bets so go do that you guys will
take advantage of it you guys want to
hear about some vibes
johnson101 is saying he's putting one
thousand dollars on the parlay because
he loves it that's the vibe We need oh
my God one thousand dollars
to win one thousand and ten dollars
let's go
he's putting a thousand dollars oh my
gosh that stresses me out now oh no why
would anybody be stressed it's just
money the way everybody talk the way
everybody talk in the comments
everybody's Rich it's just a thousand
dollars
come on now
why not make it five let's go
yeah that's Hey listen man I'm glad he
loves the parlay that much I mean I love
the parlay too so
yeah
oh that's my boy that's my boy yeah that
he winners only yeah okay yeah hey let's
hide it bro what's up with it yeah yeah
he's gonna put the band on it you know
how winners only do you know he comes
from Big bankroll nah but uh let's talk
about Best Bets for tonight best best
for tonight I'll start this thing off
man I'll start this thing off
I want you guys to take a real real hard
look at BAM out of bio
he kind of laid the bed as far as the
numbers in the last game but you guys
Ryan I'm pretty sure you're well aware
it was a blowout you know things happen
in the blowout things happening yeah
but uh you know the numbers weren't
there last game but I firmly believe
like you know when I think that
tonight's going to be a competitive game
and when the game is competitive I think
bam out of Bio his numbers show that he
he he he plays he plays hard he plays
hard and I mean by going to go grab
rebounds and also scoring so with that
being said
my man bam out of bio
to record a double double tonight is
sitting at plus money I got it at plus
money it's still at plus money go check
it out go ponder it think about it put
that thing in because I think it's going
to be a close game tonight and uh Bam's
gonna be out there working he's going to
be out there working so MB you go next
and then Ryan you can uh hit third today
all right I think Ryan's gonna like
where my head's at right now I'm gonna
listen I'm as I'm as big a Jimmy Butler
fan as there is on the planet he was a
great bull he got us through some really
fun years Derek getting hurt was tough
I am a firm believer as most people are
in the comments in our community that
the MBA will not allow this series to
end and have eight days off before the
next basketball game we have the
extender Scott Foster will be
officiating tonight's game you know how
many times the Heat have won when he's
officiated twice in the last 14 games
two
there's no way the Celtics are going to
lose tonight and they are plus money
I don't understand it and let me tell
you I think that Jalen Brown is a fraud
I think just Jason Tatum is there he's
close he's there
but I don't think these guys could win a
championship just them too but God damn
it tonight
they are going to win the game
and give us another game this week so we
can come back and make another winning
parlay on Thursday but I don't see them
winning the series just give me the
money line tonight
well I'm gonna forget the mail
[Laughter]
hey before Ryan gets in I just I I'll
just say this hand up I don't think JT's
there yet I don't I I don't think he's
there first team all NBA
I I don't think he's there it doesn't
happen last year okay okay what happened
last year he was in the finals he won
yesterday Finals MVP what happened in
the finals did he show up or did he know
I don't uh we talk about Joel B like
he's a God we talk about Jimmy Butler
like he's a God those guys he's never
been to the Eastern Conference Finals
Jimmy Butler's never been to a finals
just played in the finals like a couple
years ago that doesn't count 2020
doesn't count
it counts well if you're gonna count if
you're gonna come to Ellen beads MVP I
mean like nobody's really talking about
John B anymore because the actual MVP is
playing in the finals so it really
doesn't matter what you do in the
regular season if you're not holding the
title you're acting like finals
bowling we're on the same side what are
we doing
no I don't want to argue with you I'm
just saying it may not be the guys they
just might be guys they may not be you
know like the man of the people or um
but not like say it JT say JT's not that
guys he holds the NBA record for most
points at a game seven that was that
happened sees it by the way he's played
really well he's a great player but I
think he has potential to be that guy he
definitely has potential to be that guy
don't get me wrong here but right now
May 23rd
at approximately 5 53 Eastern Standard
Time yeah I don't think JT is that guy
yo okay so before I get to mine I gotta
ask the chat am I am I crazy am I
ludicrous for thinking this way or are
these guys talking out of their ass I
need to know I need to know who's who
who is crazy right now me or that okay
one of us is insane
here's the deal
I think JT is real I don't think Jalen
Brown is yeah if you ask better if you
ask betters if you ask betters what they
think of these two guys I can guarantee
you 75 or maybe more would say they're
both not that guy because they've been
smoking parlays all postseason long it's
just facts it's just facts
okay all right so here's uh well I'm
moving I'm moving off of this
you can't ask the audience see man or
the people you can't ask the audience a
question and then when they respond you
move on from them you have to entertain
the audience and uh KJ mother he says
you're crazy and then he also says JT
isn't that guy he doesn't have a he
doesn't have what it takes to win the
I agree it's that guy right okay
wow you're okay I just just so just so
you guys know this what I keep these
clips look at the comments I'm reading
them I'm listening to you too
all right bro they're saying you you're
crazy I know I know
uh Ian Evans friend of the program has
been on here before says uh need Celtics
money line more than I need air to
breathe yes also bowling I'm just gonna
say this to you right now dude if you're
gonna take Celtics money line tonight
you might as well do yourself a favor go
over here
go to the Easter Conference Finals and
go take them they're plus 800 earlier
today they're plus 700 now and go do
that don't let the Celtics win tonight's
game that I said it all day I've tweeted
it all day don't do it don't do it
because they're gonna go home they're
gonna win game five at home and then all
of a sudden all of a sudden the mounting
pressures on the Miami Heat back at home
for game six that's all I'll say and
then it's who handles the pressure
better
that's it that's it I like it don't have
the bubble to save you anymore Greg they
don't have the bubble to save them
anymore
not you I ain't right not that that
wasn't personal you're sorry that was
hey I totally understand bro I totally
get it I was there I was right there
where you were a couple days ago and so
I I I'm sending you Good Vibes bro I
hope the Celtics you know make it
interesting for you I want everyone in
here everyone in here who's been calling
me crazy to come back here on Thursday
and see if they got that same energy
Hey listen
I I like I said I like the Celtics
tonight I do not think they're gonna win
the series and if you think that's value
at plus 700 it is no team has ever come
back from never I was talking to bagel
and locks zero for 149 this number
should be closer to plus a thousand or
plus a hundred like I don't know if
you're buying in at seven to one that
ship is sailed brother I don't think
it's we'll see though all right I'm just
saying there's a reason it's seven to
one because all these boys gotta do is
wake up uh my guy Darian back in here
saying I'm with you Ryan Shady will
always be that guy see I got one and of
course it's Darian love Darian all right
um my best bet real quick is that your
best bet yep yeah sorry that was a huge
side tangent
um but okay uh I've been fading
Superstars uh for the better part of two
weeks now
um got off to 6-0
UH 60 start uh you know some things
happen Nikolai jokic happened really
um and now I'm 86. so I'm flipping the
script and I'm riding with a superstar
tonight uh and if you haven't been able
to tell who I love tonight
um while reveal it for you now it's
Jason Tatum over 29 and a half points
average is 27 points in elimination
games I think he he's heard everything
that's been said the past two days about
the Celtics about how they've quit about
how these got a you know a certain
member of the media who is a former
Celtic says to now said to break up the
Jays then said don't break up the Jays
it is now saying break up the Jays again
um so let's just I'll leave it at that
but has heard all of this and is saying
that's it I've had enough I'm taking
things into my own hands and I think if
the Celtics are gonna win tonight it's
going to be on the back of Jason Tatum
uh I'm in on him at 35 Plus points
tonight I'm also in on him at over 29
and a half points I think that's the
safer one obviously yeah this is going
to smack Thank Me Later again when we
when we're doing the show on Thursday
because there will be a game five uh you
can come in here you can thank thank me
handshake emojis we'll we'll all
celebrate a little bit
um but over 29.5 points tonight for
Jason Tatum
um let's not forget who he is okay let's
not forget humbly
players in the world
humbly yeah flip it out Greg clip it out
yeah you are a Ryan we're here because
you already know what I was gonna say
let's not forget what Ryan just said
clip that out clip that out that needs
to be ran on next show top of the show
we'll see if Ryan was right well you
know we'll either be happy we'll either
be giving them those handshakes or we'll
be like uh right you gotta go sit on
punishment maybe chest chest bump into
the camera uh also shout out to KJ
Mullins yeah a little bit of that uh KJ
Mullins uh it's been giving me a hard
time but also said Ryan's a die-hard uh
fan for his Celtics I'm the same way
about Miami respect sir respect
big says it's over tonight no game five
so might not be a celebration if we
don't win tonight the next show will be
the following week we'll be talking
about heat nuggets so I don't know man
my money's on the Celtics I hope you
guys can can pull through and we'll see
we'll see who steps up someone's got to
step up or else they're not gonna win so
uh guys let's go get some money man it's
time to get on up out of here
uh Ryan
sir can we get I'll I'll read it I'll
read it can we get the can we get the
parlay up one more time before we get up
out of here just for the people that
came in late they're the parlay is there
it is and we are you know we're taking
our chances at uh just seeing one go
through the hoop we're just trying to
see one go through the hoop so we got uh
Calvin Martin one plus three pointers
made uh struce over eight and a half
points we got Tatum for 20 plus points
Horford one plus three point made and
Marcus Smart
one plus three point made there it is
probably sitting at plus 110 uh but guys
later man let's go win some money
first basket Market Smart Plus 1100 Dave
Vincent plus 1100 going with the point
guards tonight let's get some value
because the series might be over we
don't know yet we don't know yet
we gotta see if the Jays are gonna make
some jump shots today
well we'll see I put my faith in you
right
now
I don't know if that's true I don't know
that's true I think that's true
that's debatable but hey we about this
thing y'all peace
[Music]
come on
everything
[Applause]
[Music]